Dan Majerle the head coach at Grand
Canyon University they had a great great
season this year
dan 3-time NBA all-star course played
for the Phoenix Suns and one of the
great three-point shooters of all time
good to see you looks off guy and the
soft guy now could you play how many
minutes could you play right now
probably one minute yeah how many shots
I could probably get 10 shots what's the
most shots most threes you ever took not
made but most you ever took oh I don't
think there were many I may be 12 or 11
I didn't take a lot but you in a game
yeah but yeah back when did it start
becoming a weapon it was you know when I
first and I heard you talk about when I
first got in the league I was a slasher
dunker and then we traded for Charles in
92 and we had to give up Jeff hornacek
and so they're gonna move me to shooting
guard so I literally with your guy AJ
lived in a gym and shot jumpers every
night five to five hundred to a thousand
jumpers every night because I knew that
you know throwing the ball and Charles
would get double-teamed and that's when
I became a guy shot jumpers because of
Charles but were you known as did you
have any kind of jumper going was he a
bad it wasn't bad but no I was more of
and then you know I had you know three
back surgeries and ankle surgeries as I
got older I was it was hard to get to
the rim and so I moved to two more
outside player but no I just worked on
it and I tell my players all the time
you could become a a really good shooter
it just takes a lot of practice but I
look at you and your size and it is
Charles Barkley shorter than you yeah
like I try to tell people never sold
Charles play because people look at
Charles now and they think he's you know
entertaining and kind of goofy but here
he is the size of Buddy hield
but he was going against Jack he anyone
ever see anything like it Charles is
probably maybe six five and I'm six six
I think and so wide his lower body is so
wide and he's not big up here he's not a
big but his lower body is so strong and
just the way he dominated the pain at
his size his explosiveness we boxed out
the way he jumped his quickness
there was nobody like him I mean you're
right he would guard guys like Shaq and
all these bigger
guys and he would just control him with
his little bot or with his lower body it
was unbelievable but you remember when
he took down Shaq
yeah I've seen Charles they've got a lot
of people but but they let it go for a
little while yeah why that's the way it
was I mean Charles as Charles was not
and we talked about her Charles is not a
great practice player in fact we would
not let him practice no cuz he would
mess up practice but when the lights
came on and the game started there was
nobody like him as far as a competitor
he was unbelievable he would you know
take the whole team on his shoulders and
just Willis this and win so what's your
favorite Charles story I don't know I
think there's a lot of court on the
court yet just you know I don't know I
don't he was just such an amazing guy
that but was he a trash talker yeah he
would talk trash talk to the other team
to the you know the officials to
everybody he would trash talk to us
sometimes so he just got it going and he
would it's almost to a point we said
Charles just got to settle down but he
just enjoyed the game so much and played
so hard it was fun I mean I've never had
a teammate like him and because of that
you know that first year that we had him
in 92 93 is the first year that we
opened the arena we 162 games we had the
best record in the league you know
played against Michael and those guys
and you know he was like a rock star
like traveling around the Beatles he's
Thunder Dan Majerle Grand Canyon
University head coach the the Duke of
Arizona
what was your record this year 27 and
seven nice yeah it was good you know
we're in a third year of transition from
Division one the first year we won 15
games then we were 17 and 15 and this
year we went 27 and 7 we have one more
year in the transition before we can
play in the tournament so we're excited
we had a really good year we had some
great wins we beat San Diego State at
San Diego State we beat Houston we beat
New Mexico State whose arrival as ours
in the WAC at home so we made some great
strides and some great steps to where we
want to go so it's fun were you the best
basketball team in the state of Arizona
no we got a long way to go would you
like to have a piece of Arizona well
we're gonna get a fortunate yeah we play
them next year you got Duke in Arizona
no yeah we start off at Duke grat you
we're at Penn State we're at Illinois
and then we have Louisville and we have
San Diego State on campus playing next
year so we have a pretty good schedule
so Arizona's really good obviously and
we'll see how we hold up but I was hired
at Grand Canyon make a top 25 team we're
a long ways from that we've makes we've
made strides and we just got to keep
going what do you make of the Final Four
here with these teams have you have you
had time to even look at watch see I
watched a little bit of it you know you
get so busy and doing different things
but I love it you know that's been a in
the first week with the upsets and
Michigan State losing and breaking my
bracket right away you're not alone
there yeah I know everybody did that but
the run that Syracuse has is great did
you have much March Madness at Central
Michigan I had one year and I'd know
Reggie was here we had my junior year I
think we're either 16th seed and they
were the first seed so it lasted wasn't
very long Reggie did you guard Reggie no
I was I was a Senator in college I think
I guarded so yeah I was the senator in
college so I remember playing I think I
had 17 and 12 or something and we got
they just blew our doors off so that was
my short stint in the NCAA tournament I
also I wonder about this when you when
you get to the NBA
you know you're facing great scorers
every night so somebody's got a guard
Steph Curry and they know he could put
up 50 or somebody guarding Kobe and he
could put up 81 were you ever a not
afraid but nervous that you were going
to be embarrassed by guarding somebody
in the NBA I looked at it I mean I love
Garden Jordan you know it's when I was
with the Suns
I was always put on the best player like
I would Garwin before Charles came to to
to Phoenix I would guard him the
Philadelphia would guard Carl Malone I
would guard always the best player so
why does a challenge and I loved it I
think that was you know you knew you're
gonna get scored on he just tried not to
get you know as you said embarrassed and
that's why I never said anything to
Jordan or just I just kind of went about
my business tasks about how his drives
nuts were and what would you know what
what clubs he's using but America you're
better at him in golf aren't you I don't
know we've never played but like a
chance oh I think um I think you might
be a little better than Mike there I
don't know but it was fun playing
against those guys and I I enjoyed it
every night like garden Reggie
you're gonna know you're gonna run off
screens all night I just took it as
challenge and something I look forward
to the Steph Curry effect I'm talking to
Reggie about that that you see these
kids now you're recruiting these kids
out of high school are we seeing them
wanting to be like Steph Curry trying to
play like that hope I find a few but he
wanted Davidson yeah that's why I said
that's what that's what we need a Grand
Canyon obviously we're not gonna get
anyone and Dunn's right now we got to
find guys who are a little under the
radar and can develop into great players
and that's the hardest thing as a
coaches is trying to find those guys and
look at him and see what they maybe
three or four years from now so yeah you
know I got a son who's 13 years old and
he loves stuff that's his favorite
player and I'd take him out in the
backyard that's all he's doing he's
doing the step back in the dribbles and
all that stuff and you know he shoots
about you know 50 jump shots and about
one of them go into something it's not
making a shot max I mean you look good
yeah making one yeah I know we always
talking about looked at I crossed
somebody over I made somebody trip and I
did all that stuff I said well it'd be
nice to be made one could you imagine
playing now with how we embrace the
three-point shot would be great you know
like I said I think you know it steps in
a whole nother world
it's amazing that what he does but back
then we didn't take shots like that
I'm Yaak I you know I used to take deep
3 yeah and I used to do it but I
wouldn't do it regularly I just come
down and shoot it so he's great at what
he does it's amazing but yeah we didn't
we didn't really have that kind of
freedom if I said you could have LeBron
for ten years or Larry Bird for ten
years Larry that's just my ear I grew up
idolizing Larry Bird it was plenty the
first time that I played in my rookie
year I guarded Larry Bird and it took me
about ten minutes to realize I should be
probably guarding him said of Stan he
came down I was it was funny he came
down with time and Mark West was the
center on our team and and Larry looked
at me and he then he looked at Mark II
he said mark I'm gonna go down and come
off the screen I'm gonna come off the
screen I'm gonna catch it right there
I'm gonna turn around I'm gonna shoot it
the rookie space and then I'm gonna run
down the floor and that's exactly what
and I'm sitting there that just happened
that's pretty cool so I was a huge Larry
Bird fan and got to know him a little
bit but yes I would take just
I think his overall game obviously
LeBron is great but I was Larry Bird fan
but did he talk to you or you work
through me he never addressed
he went talk he would imagine we had no
time from he just talked right through
me to Marquess it's always good like I
wouldn't even there and did Marquess be
mark West Clark was like okay hey Mark
mark I'm going take the rookie down let
him turn to shoot a jumper his face on
the floor and then he did that was my
burden prescient impression there Larry
Larry Cooper but he did that to Xavier
McDaniel
he said ex i'ma get the ball mmm I'm
gonna take a jumper right this was
game-winner in Seattle yeah he says hex
I'm gonna get the ball almost shoot it
right here right in your face for
game-winner and he did so you know
Xavier McDaniel was the tough guys one I
played with action here in Phoenix yeah
and he was a tough guy and and that's
why we got X and I love him that's why
we got X and he got the Phoenix though
that's none made of soft oh you think
that's what I was I didn't get softer
they come to feed did you get Sean you
told me I was song you did you got a
little softer I was what Dan saw you
were tan Marley well I played everybody
says I'm always a fan of my 14 years I
played in Phoenix in Miami and I had one
year in Cleveland and if you look at my
pictures in Cleveland I was always in
the dance do you have a tanning bed no
okay I just wanna make sure cuz I never
can tell you know that might be an NCAA
violation it might be but I know I wish
now I play a little bit of golf what I
have time but you get tan walking from
the from the the car to the gym by the
way we're giving away tickets to the
Final Four so you've seen some of these
hours on display here good shot
no no not really you actually took a
jumper that was nice when's the last
time you got out and do you shoot with
your are you the best shooter on your
team unfortunately you are yeah that
might be some of our problem yes Bullock
we have a thunder Dan
stat for you to put in a good no your
best game ever from three this is the
record for most out of three you were 9
for 10 January 2000 against Minnesota
yes Steph Curry's best game was 11 of 13
84% Dan Marley's best game 90% do you
think it's a sign that we have and
there's thunder hey the funny thing
about that game is I was I was playing
with Miami right I took a shot I think
right before half and it went in and out
that's the only one I missed and that's
one of those days where you just get hot
yeah and I was we were in Minnesota and
I swear to you I was shooting 40-footers
and the crowd was going crazy and they
were telling me to shoot and there was
just I couldn't miss I was just I would
just pull up and just it was like stuff
and you have those days everyone stand
up hurry for one day hey-ya is the voice
due to this season or is it due to last
night's due to the season last night I
went crazy last night I think I stayed
out to like 11:30 yeah I got not you are
one yeah but it's it's I've learned it I
don't have a voice during the season I
coach a lot like I played which is not
soft but pretty intense I get after my
guys and I really enjoy it so I don't
have much of a voice most of the year
well it's always great to see I saw you
bring it
you brought it free yeah well it's just
a verbal commitment here that I'm gonna
have for a Grand Canyon no binding yes I
you asked me how many minutes can you
play I can give you 15 that's all I need
come on
and last might not I lost my nephew this
year he's the seniors a really good
shooter so okay then just put you in the
corner
yeah feed you the ball especially
against the zone yeah oh you're at the
guard anybody because we don't really
garden I can't guard yet but Sean Miller
reached out to me as well to see if I
wonder to play Bobby Hurley reached out
to me as well so I'm gonna have to see
what they can give me under the table
yep we should have just stopped right
before the jury
we sell out our arena we have 7,200 fans
we sell it every night we have a great
arena unbelievable student section
called the Havoc's that just go notch
and I played it and we'll play it Duke
next year as we talked about in there
they got great student section but GCU
rivals any place I've ever been as far
as excitement and atmosphere it's great
to have you here yeah I appreciate and
I'm gonna I'm gonna commit I have two
years of eligibility perfect so I will
play four grand on next year and then
now we have summer school starting in
June so come on I don't go to school I'm
the Ben Simmons of Grand Canyon I'm not
going to class we actually had real
quick I know we got to go but Josh
Braun's our sophomore he was the
first-team academic all-american this
year at the Grand Canyon first-team
academic all-american so we're really
proud of that I'll cheat off his paper
yes that's what we do is he's our best
player he's Dan Majerle Thunder damn you
city guys thank Grand Canyon University
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience